i would start right now so ryan if
you're feeling ready
we'll get started yeah okay
um good so um
just so we're very pleased to have uh
ryan giving our
second talk of today um you'll be
talking about the usefulness of the
strong exponential timeline hypothesis
orion is a professor at mit he's well
known for his work on
complexity in a variety of areas
including a
non-deterministic exponential time
fine-grained complexity
sat out valve algorithms and so forth
uh he's been wisely working with sad
algorithms for many years so
is i think starting with his back with
his backdoor work
i want to say sometime in the 80s but
maybe i'm wrong about that date
so 80s no when was it
yeah i i'm not that old sam you're not
that old no no mine's way younger
so uh my when was that don't don't even
look it up
working that was that was 2003 right
yeah yeah okay sorry about that
i should from there so uh anyway
it's a pleasure to have ryan here and
the floor is yours
thanks sam thanks uh thanks to the
organizers for asking me to speak
um yeah i feel a little weird giving a
talk in a workshop on 50 years of
satisfiability certainly
i haven't been active in research for
many of those years but
after i thought more about it i realized
i do have some kind of history to tell i
hope you will find
my stories interesting um i don't
actually guarantee 100
satisfaction with this talk um
yeah it's it's some kind of talk and you
know maybe
yeah i hope everybody will get something
out of it we'll see
so uh before i begin i'm gonna make sure
that we're on the same
page with the with a notation for set
so so i'm going to refer to spat as just
satisfiable boolean formulas and c and f
i'm not going to look at anything beyond
conjunctive normal form uh
ksat will be cnf set where all clauses
have at most k literals
um if you don't know what those some of
those terms mean
probably this is not the talk for you
it's probably not the the
uh workshop for you okay so two measures
the size of the formula i will always
use
n to mean uh the number of variables and
m to be the number of clauses okay
um just for the fixed notation
so the best known worst case running
times um
for sat and ksat as a function of
m n and k um are not so great so
as we all know and um if you've been
following these
talks at simon's set is solved all the
time in practice
set solvers are great but unfortunately
there are instances in which they can do
really badly
so the best case so the best known worst
case running times
um look like the following so
so for sat uh this was first achieved i
think by
a calabro implies in 2006.
um uh two to the n
minus n over order log mn okay so
think of it this way if the clause to
variable ratio
m over n is a constant then you can
improve
uh the base of the exponent and you're
running time by
a constant but if the number of clauses
is say
anything larger than a constant times n
let's say they're polynomially many
clauses then
this running time is getting closer and
closer to 2 to the n
now for for k set we know that for every
constant k
you can get some improvement over to the
n so the exponent instead of being
just to the n is to the n minus
n over order k in the exponent okay but
again
um this is getting worse and worse as k
is increasing right you're dividing by
you're dividing by
a larger term and that's in that part
you're subtracting out
so the this exponent is getting worse
and worse and this was first achieved as
far as i know by pp
z in 1997 um
pudlock paturi and zane okay
um so there are dozens of dozens of
other papers on
worst case case set albums if i were to
start listing them properly
i'd use a lot of time i don't have if we
have if we look at just these big out
terms
then um these are really the best
known worst case running times it's a
function of m n and k
now subsequent improvements have
improved these big o's but
again we seem to have this kind of
inherent dependence uh
on k the the running time improvement
gets worse and worse as k
is increasing or as the number of
clauses gets larger and larger the
running time gets worse
either way and there's a sense in which
um
which calabro and piles and patery also
show that
there's a connection between these two
exponents
okay so the big question uh for
theory people is can we improve the
exponents uh for these running times so
can
can we show um that sat
is in 1.99 to the end time okay
um maybe more ambitious thing is to ask
is
say three set into the epsilon end time
for every epsilon
so can i get um 1.0001 to the end time
for 3sat for
and can i put 1.00 for any string of
zeros i want
uh one to the end time so again i can
just keep making the running time
exponent better and better and it's
known that through
uh mp completeness reductions this would
imply that all of ksat has a similar
running time okay this is so the
exponential time
hypothesis of ipc and polyester pretty
insane conjectures know
that this is not possible okay and this
is a vast vast strengthening of pdf from
mp
pvmp is saying three set is not in p
we're saying it's not even in
sub-exponential time
right right so this is a restatement of
so-called e-t-h exponential time
hypothesis
um another question is maybe a weaker
question is
is k-set in 1.9999 to the end time for
some string of knights okay so
is k-sat into the delta n times
poly m time for some universal delta
less than one so
can i get like some fixed exponent
improvement regardless of what k is so
the universal means is independent of k
so strong eth uh conjectures
know that that this is not possible
okay so more formally uh
for all possible improvements in the
exponent you know
something less than two to the n there
is some clause with k so the case head
is not in
to that improvement uh times n okay
so uh so this is
uh something stronger so strong eth
implies gth and
this is uh not obvious you need
something called the sparsification
lemma
um to to prove this but
uh so these are the two main conjectures
though uh about the worst case
complexity of sap problem
and they've been very useful okay so
especially
uh seth or strong eth i like to say
strong he h
so as not to i don't know um bother
people who are named seth
um these hypotheses they give many
complexity predictions okay
for for problems in mp naturally but
also problems within
polynomial time um so you can show that
various final time algorithms are
optimal
uh assuming this uh strong eth okay
and so far both these hypotheses are
nicely consistent with general wisdom so
they are useful in a sense okay um
so what's the point of this talk after
setting out um
you know the the main subjects of
discussion
so what do i mean by the usefulness of
strong ath
so it could mean i'm about to give a
talk about all these amazing
consequences that
seth has the rest of theoretical
computer science like it's at the heart
of something called fine grain
complexity that
russell was talking about in the last
seminar of this kind
um yeah i could be discussing uh
fingering and blexi all the implications
of
of of seth um well i mean for me
uh you know if i'm going to be uh
brutally honest about everything well
i i believe strong eth is false okay
um my belief is probably the minority of
opinion at this point
and it hey it may even be wrong
um but the chances i'll be proved my
wrong in my lifetime or nil um right
i mean like uh i'd be super happy if
someone proves drawing age is true but
that's so much stronger than peter from
mp um
yeah i think i'm probably safe uh in
that sense
but regardless uh the point of this talk
is that this belief
that strong dangerous false independent
of its truth value it's been extremely
useful
uh for me it's been extremely useful and
so even if it turns out to be true
my belief in the opposite has led me to
many algorithmic ideas
and which led to complexity ideas that
i've never and i've never found
otherwise
so i'll tell you about these ideas so
that's what this talk is about um
this is i mean i can't tell you about
all the results i approve of trying to
refute strong th like you know i have a
lot of uh failures
um but this will be actually a history
talk
it'll be a history of my uh many
failures to refute strong th
um and you know uh
recovery from the failure i hope you
will enjoy my futility
all right uh let's see so
so how did i get into this the first
place why did i start thinking about
this at all
um so some years ago
uh in ithaca new york i was a teenager
and i thought that threesat wasn't
np okay well i mean since i only believe
the negation
of uh strong adh now i guess
in some sense some progress has been
made okay uh you know like i used to
believe p equals np and now
i only believe negation is trying to h
okay
um so i learned about various cases
albums from john kleinberg's class
uh on on algorithms and in fact my early
belief in p equals mp is how i met
uh scott aronson other complexity
theorists you might have heard of we
were both undergrads
at cornell we were participating in some
uh cs project fair and he saw my project
that was basically claiming people's mp
and he sent me an email later saying you
know you don't have to directly solve
three set and pawn on time there's this
result
which says you only have to satisfy
seven eighths plus epsilon the clauses
of a three c formula important time and
so
this is how i learned about the pcp
theory from scott
okay um anyway yeah we were teenagers we
thought we knew it all
um so
in july one i submitted a paper to soda
uh on solving quantifiability and
formula slightly faster than exhaustive
search in some cases
uh this was just from trying to
uh fix various algorithms that were
uh trying trying to solve three set
point on time
and uh somehow uh the paper got in uh
and still i'm not sure why the all the
reviews were blank
um but gerhard vergenger saw it and he
was writing a survey about exact art and
he sent me
a draft for comment um so we had two
open problems which are very interesting
uh one was to design exact algorithm for
max cut
with time complexity less than to the n
okay so the max cut problem you have a
graph you want to find a partition into
two
uh sets then nodes into two sets that
maximize the number of edges crossing
the cut
um another problem is assuming eth
obtain evidence for the strong th of
course
um i think at that point these were
called strong engage wasn't called
strong engage yet but
this is essentially what he said and i
became obsessed with solving these kinds
of open problems
uh i really really got into these
exponential
time exact algorithms even though uh you
know it was not very uh trendy
or uh popular to do so um
you know it just seemed like interesting
problems to me like
there's a dumb algorithm that runs into
the end uh is this dumb algorithm the
best you can do
can you get 1.9 to the end um this
just seemed like uh fundamentally uh
basic and interesting problems
um so okay so some years ago
in in pittsburgh i was a grad student
and i was thinking about these problems
and i became enamored
of the end of the omega time algorithm
for finding a triangle
in an endnote graph of the italian rhode
a this is such a beautiful algorithm it
doesn't take long to describe
it so let me do that so what they show
is that if m by matrices can be
multiplied
in m to the omega additions and
multiplications
then three clique or the triangle
problem so trying to find a triangle in
the graph
three nodes that have all edges
connected this isn't into the omega time
and we know that omega is less than 2.4
christos mentioned strawson's algorithms
made these kinds of developments
possible
the first hourly beating the naive uh in
cubed alright
the latest improvement is from earlier
this year
so at its most fundamental level italian
road air showing how a problem with an
n-cube side's
search space can be searched into 2.4
time instead
somehow you can prune this search space
and and get something with a better
exponent
okay so here's the proof it's it's quite
short
let a be the adjacent matrix of our
given graph okay
and let b be uh the square of this
matrix we multiply the matrix with
itself
okay and so the claim is that there is a
three clique in the graph
if and only if there are entries i and j
um where a i j is one
and b i j is is not a zero
okay now so it's very easy to see why
this uh works so
what does it mean for bij to be non-zero
it means the sum over all k of aik times
akj is not zero okay and that can only
happen
if there is some vertex k so that i have
an edge from i to k and have edge from k
to j
uh right this sum is it's just a sum of
uh uh products of zeros and ones right
and if aij is one that means i have an
edge from i to j
okay and so i i get a triangle right and
this is the only way i can get a
triangle um
so it's an if and only if and it's very
clean you just take the matrix
square it we know we can do that in in
the omega time and then we check
um for we check this condition for all i
and j
okay um very very simple very beautiful
little algorithm showing how this faster
matrix multiplication
is can actually be used to prune like a
search space in an arbitrary graph
okay so i wanted to use this um
so in fact you can count the three
clicks okay so i wanted to use this
uh to to somehow solve sat faster or
some
mp heart problem faster so suppose we
just thought of n
cubed as 2 to the k for some k all right
i mean maybe k is like the number of
variables in some other problem
then uh into the omega would be about uh
1.74 to the k okay
um so so that would be you know if this
were like two to the n
for running time we bid 1.8 to the n
running time
okay so if we could somehow embed a sat
problem
into some triangle finding instance uh
with this property maybe maybe we could
uh solve that faster
okay so so i had this idea
um to express c n of sat on k variables
as an instance of triangle detection
on two to the k over three nodes right
so if if we could do that
right if we could take c m sat on k
variables and express it as triangle
detection
to the k over three nodes then you know
plugging this
stuff in we would have it um 1.8 to the
n
time algorithm for cnf set on in
variables would be done right
joint h would be false okay well of
course i failed
as we call the strong age is still
choose for we know edges can only encode
so much i was trying to push all kinds
of information onto edges
trying to encode like various conditions
of like the c and f
it just seems that edges can only encode
so much
but i noticed later the edges canon code
constraints on two variables
so if i'm looking at instead of like a
full cnf i'm looking at
clauses on two variables i can encode
these constraints with edges
all right well we already know that two
sat is solvable and upon all time
but in fact uh we can do a bit more we
can in fact solve
any uh sort of optimization problem on
uh two variable constraints uh faster so
this turns out to show that max cut can
be solved uh
slightly faster than to the end solving
gerhart's open problem
and max2sat can be solved in a bunch of
other like optimization problems
if you want to solve them exactly you
can actually beat uh exhaustive search
okay uh so this eventually appeared in
my uh
in my phd thesis up here in icalc 2004
um along the way i was trying to find
okay
you know this one thing worked this this
exponential time reduction
really is what's going on exponential
time reduction uh
from an mp hard problem like max cut to
triangle finding it worked
so can i if maybe if i just find the
correct funnel time problem to reduce to
if i take you know c and f set reduce to
another polynomial time problem
maybe that would work okay i found like
many many final time problems whose
faster solution
would refute strong ph but i failed to
solve any of them faster
so far but you know taking the
contrapositives of all these
theorems that end up forming uh what is
what is now
partly forming what is now fine-grained
complexity because assuming showing th
it means that all these funnel time
problems cannot have faster
uh algorithms all right so so that's
kind of how it worked
um so here are some of the results i'll
just
briefly mention so it's okay dominating
set is a very
important problem in parametrized
complexity
which stefan zeider talked about a bit
yesterday so
so given a graph we want to find a set
of nodes
uh of size uh in most k such that that
set
union with its neighborhood is the whole
vertex set
okay so this is solvable um so the naive
algorithm will take
into the k plus one you can solve it uh
close to in the k using matrix
multiplication tricks
um so we showed and this is work with uh
uh mihai petrosku uh eventually appeared
in
soda 2010. if you could solve it
slightly faster just even slightly
faster for some k and for some epsilon
then uh seth is false um
there's this other problem two sat two
given a two c and f
with two extra clauses of arbitrary
length is it satisfiable
um maybe i can skip over this but
basically there's a naive
way to solve it in square if you can
solve it faster it says it's false
there's this problem d sum given in
numbers are the d that sum to zero
even the case of threesome is actually
fundamental in computational geometry
um uh a lot of hardness
of polynomial time problems is based on
the assumption that three sum
can't be solved faster so we know that
solve an into the ceiling
of d over two time and that ceiling is
somehow important um
it means that three sum takes n squared
time and we don't know how to solve it
faster than
in squared time um we we show that if
eth is true then d sum
has this kind of inherent curse of
dimensionality
uh so you get uh
into the omega d uh time
uh running time under ath and then
finally there's this
very simple problem called orthogonal
vectors uh which i was studying
given a set of n binary d dimensional
vectors
okay are there two with inner product
equal to zero okay so just have a bunch
of zero one vectors
i wanna know if there's two whose inner
product is zero really simple problem
okay um it's easy to solve in quadratic
time just try all
possible pairs of vectors um compute the
inner product
uh we show that if you could solve it
slightly faster than squared time
then e t h is false okay and
um so everyone cites these papers uh as
showing conditional hardness of various
time problems uh
seth wow if you just take the contra
positive like seth implies like all this
like tight hardness of stuff and
and it led to a lot of other things so
for example the
the proof so it's it's known by bockers
and
and indic that uh computing edit
distance
needs uh essentially n squared time
under seth
and it goes through this orthogonal
vectors problem
um so yeah of course
i came about it trying to refute joining
th
but you know it's it's nice to have a
win even when you fail
so you know that's that's what this talk
is all about i guess uh
right so let me uh
mention how a faster ov will imply
the negation of seth because the
reduction is is so
simple you can teach it to undergrads um
so again like if we can solve orthogonal
vectors with capital n vectors
in slightly faster than quadratic time
then sat can be solved slightly faster
than 2 to the n
okay and this implies by this so-called
specification limit specification
basically says
that for kcnf formulas the hardest case
is when there's a linear number of
clauses
okay so then we don't have to worry
about this whatever factor of uh
d here the dependence on the dimension
or the number of clauses
so so this wouldn't refute uh strong ath
we have a
explicit uh epsilon that gets us faster
running time
so here's the proof sketch so given a
cnf with n variables and m clauses
we are going to do an exponential time
reduction we're going to construct a set
of two to the n over two let's say plus
one
vectors so that'll be our capital n and
they'll have m plus two dimensions so
number of clauses plus two
uh so that this set has an orthogonal
pair
if and only if the original formula is
satisfiable okay
and so if i can solve uh this problem
faster than quadratic time faster than
capital n squared i'll get a faster
uh sad algorithm okay so let me see
how the reduction works so we split the
n variables into two parts p1 and p2
and they have about uh n over two
variables each we could even assume
uh n is even so they have exactly n over
two variables each
then we make vectors for all assignments
to the variables in a part
okay this is how we get this capital in
uh here
so we'll have like two to the n over two
vectors for the assignments to p1
and to the n over two vectors for the
assignments of p2 right so we'll make
vectors for all of them
and here's how we make the vectors for
all assignments a and p one we make a
vector
v sub a which has an m plus one
component one
n plus two component zero okay
and for all other components i one
uh through m the ith component is one
if and only if the assignment a doesn't
satisfy the ith clause of the formula
okay so we put a one if if you're not
satisfying and a zero if you do satisfy
okay and we do a similar thing for p2
except
we add we flip the bits here for m1 and
m2
to force us to when we pick an
orthogonal pair
we've got to pick something from p1 and
something from p2 if we pick
two vectors from you know this of the
same form they won't be orthogonal so
so it's just enforcing orthogonality
here and then we
we had the same uh definitions before
okay so
we're putting zeros and ones saying
whether or not you satisfy the eighth
clause
and then um it's easy to see that
orthogonal pairs
in this new instance directly correspond
to stat assignments so every orthogonal
pair
here directly corresponds to some
assignment on the variables in p1
in the assignments and the variables in
p2 that satisfies all the clause because
the inner product is zero
it must be in every component there's at
least one zero well that means that it
either you know the partial assignment a
satisfies it clause or the other partial
assignment satisfies that clause
all right so that's it and um so then if
we have ov and subquadratic time
then we will get a faster saturn all
right
um yeah but this is one of many many
subjects it's probably the simplest
such reductions showing how you know the
contrapositive is
if seth is true then in fact the this
very simple
quadratic time algorithm is in fact
optimal
all right all right so about 10 years
ago
uh in san jose california i was
doing yet another approach to solving uh
cnf set
um and then the idea here was
i would try to solve cnfsat by
expressing it as a problem on
multivariate polynomials so do some kind
of
so-called algebraization of the problem
then
i would want to use like algebraic
algorithms like the fast fourier
transform to determine sat quickly so i
had
various ways of of trying to do this
trying to
use you know things like matrix
multiplication things like fast fourier
transform
things you know let's take advantage of
algebraic structure and work
surprisingly fast so it solves that
using that i mean given
everything you know it done to that
point it made sense
um okay again this failed uh it failed
pretty badly
uh in fact i got cnf stat albums which
were much worse
than the best known way way worse um
but these algorithms work not only for c
and f
but they work for um things much more
expressive than cnf
as well um so they worked for ac
zero circuit so-called ac zero circuits
they even uh
worked for these so-called acc0 circuits
um
which i probably don't have any time to
explain
for the purpose of this talk acc stands
for annoying circuit class
extremely annoying circuit class um
and very difficult to analyze for no
apparent reason
um so i notice that like you can get
some kind of improvement over exhaustion
search but this is
much worse than 1.9 again i'm saying
like to the end divided by like a
quasi-polynomial say for example
um yeah so this was pretty this looked
pretty bad but it was a set algorithm
for a class that
we didn't know any lower bounds for we
knew very little about so i thought it
was kind of interesting
and i had already shown in earlier work
that if you had set algorithms
in certain cases for certain kinds of uh
circuit classes then you could get
circuit lower bounds and so
um i don't know i stayed up for many
hours
and by the next day i had improved i had
proved that this implies uh
so-called non-international exponential
time is not an acc 0.
whatever that means um this was a
notorious open problem in circuit
complexity
uh for for a couple decades at least um
and it was arguably much more
interesting than refuting seth at least
at the time
um and it i certainly would not have
found this kind of thing if i wasn't
trying to refute seth so i guess the
moral is
uh if you try to refute strong th you
might accidentally end up proving a
circuit complexity breakthrough instead
whoops um well you know that's
that's how it goes sometimes um
right so how much time do i have left
sam
uh you're muted i think
yeah it's uh you've been speaking a
little bit over
25 minutes so you still got another 15
minutes if you wish or whatever
all right all right all right i'm not
gonna be too strict about the time
all right there there are no questions
about uh all this i mean
we can pause for a moment um
yeah sybil asks a question do you want
us to speak up
uh maybe it's a comment here but
determining
d sub a is expensive and you get the
model count for free
um well for each vector this
oh so i guess you're you're talking um
this determining um for all assignments
the visa base is expensive yeah it's a
weird
um it's a weird reduction right because
it's not
um you know like at least the way i've
written it this is not the
kind of thing you would you know this is
not the kind of sat solver you'd want to
run
in practice um but yeah i'm not
sure what you mean by the model count
for free so the
the size of the instance you're getting
is really large but
this is kind of inherent if we're going
to reduce
an mp-hard problem to a polynomial time
problem like if we believe eth
and we don't believe that sat can be
solved in say
you know sub-exponential time and we're
trying to
use a polynomial time problem to solve
sat there is going to
there has to be some blow up somewhere
right in the in the
reduction from uh sat to the
oh okay okay
oh okay no problem right
yeah um yeah so it's it is a
funny way to try to solve that yeah it
is a
bizarre way uh you know i don't
recommend it as a way to solve satin
practice but if you're trying to refute
a mathematical conjecture right no holds
barred
right so this is this was uh my thinking
that like there was so much innovation
in polynomial time algorithms why not
try to leverage it
to solve sat faster um yeah
all right so yeah more failure um and
then
recovery from failure good um
yeah so may i'll talk maybe uh briefly
about the
the acc uh sat algorithm um
just but but briefly okay so this is the
acc is constant depth uh and or not
in modium uh circuits
where a modium gate takes a bunch of
bits and it outputs one if and only if
the sum of those bits is divisible
by m okay it's really
um you know this is the visibility check
uh
we're thinking so we know that like if
you don't have mod m
uh gates then there's very strong lower
bounds against constant depth circuits
so they have unbounded fan they can take
in any
number of inputs but constant depth is
you know is pretty weak as a as a
circuit class many many
uh lower balanced know but somehow when
you throw in like this mod m
um things become weird like if
the m is a prime it's okay i mean there
were techniques developed in the 80s to
prove lower bounds there but if
even if m becomes like a composite
non-prime power like six all of a sudden
uh trying to understand like a circuit
like this see here this is where the
depth is three
um and m is six circuits like this are
already like really
really difficult to understand um
somehow
uh the the techniques that we know for
proving lower bounds on circuits just
just break down
uh already in this uh apparently very
easy case so this is why i call it
annoying circuit class
it's like something for which it must be
weak but but we're all
we're stuck uh proving strong lower
balance for it and so
what i show was essentially for every
fixed m and for every
fixed depth there is some e such that
you can solve
uh the sat problem for such a circuit
of even if it's sub-exponential size to
the n minus in the epsilon or this e
time
okay all right um
yeah so the ingredients were a known
representation of acc via polymer so
everyone believed
that there should be lower bounds for
acc because
of a certain representation and um
people are still trying to prove lower
balance because of this nice
representation theorem and it goes back
to the early 90s it says that every
function computable by acc circuit so
like from from bits to a bit can be put
in the following form it can be
represented as a g of h's
where h is just some multilinear
polynomial so it has no squares
it has uh k polynomials uh
our k monomials where where k is some
quasi-polynomial in n
um over all zero one assignments this h
takes on a value between zero and k
so the point is k is not too large okay
so k is just some nice
polynomial it's it's sparse
in terms of number of monomials um
and g is just some are just some
arbitrary it can even be made a specific
type of function but it just takes a 0 1
uh sorry 0 through k value and output 0
1. okay so we can decompose acc into
this form
um and this just looks really really
easy and in fact the the degree of the
monomials are only like
log of k so in fact it's like poly log
degree uh polynomial so yeah this is
some very
tight represent very interesting
representation and uh the ingredients
are this and then
using fast fourier transform for
multilinear polynomials to evaluate them
quickly
and an interesting combination of those
i mean i think i will skip over
more details of this but um but those
are all the
main ingredients that go in so we're
using like something that people
already thought would prove lower bounds
to prove lower bounds i mean it's only
for
something like nx but that has been
improved many times over
which is not the subject of this talk uh
but yeah the point is that um
trying to refute strong th led to a
completely different thing and i just
kept going with it and
that's been a lot of my work is trying
to prove better lower bounds from sad
algorithms
uh in more recent years okay
so um one yeah well maybe two more
anecdotes uh so a few years
ago in uh stanford
i had yet another attack on seth so uh
i guess yao seth okay um so here i
i was trying to solve the orthogonal
vectors problem in subquadratic time so
we saw that
if it's solvable in less than n squared
time
uh string th is false so i was going for
something even bigger
okay and the high level idea is i was
trying to
take a circuit that expressed a group of
orthogonal vector queries like trying to
determine whether
uh a group of uh vectors had an
orthogonal pair in it
to a nice polynomial some nice polymer
and then use matrix multiply to evaluate
this polynomial quickly on many
many points um of course uh this failed
but later we managed to get some ov
albums which
turned out to imply cnf's algorithms
would there are as good as the best
known if you use
uh this reduction so the ovr rooms
really can't be
improved unless we improve the the best
known scene of sad algorithms
but however this idea which broke
uh horribly it turns out it could be
used
to compute a different kind of inner
product instead so
instead of trying to compute some group
inner product so
like like a bunch of inner products in
aggregate it could do
something else so i didn't give up on
the idea and so i was thinking about
other problems i was looking at and
so it turns out that it can be used to
solve all pairs shortest paths faster so
just to recall
all pairs shortest paths are given an
end node graph with weights on the edges
and you want to compute for all pairs of
nodes the shortest path between
the pair each pair of nodes so you could
think of it as computing the distance
there are many ways to formulate the
problem
it's a very fundamental problem in
undergrad albums courses
as a very natural uh order in cube time
algorithm first given by uh
floyd and warshall um
so the kind of inner product that i
could solve faster was this
sort of min plus inner product so it's i
guess
if you're a tropical mathematician this
would be a tropical inner product
of two things um somehow uh some people
like to think of
algebra with min and plus as tropical so
if you've got two vectors
in d dimensions the min plus inner
product uh
is you take the min over all components
k of u
k plus v k all right and it's been known
for many years that to solve all pairs
shortest paths
faster it suffices a compute faster
a min plus matrix product of two
matrices so this is where the min
has been replaced by a sum and the plus
has been replaced by multiplication and
same up here
okay so you're computing a bunch of min
plus inner products
over all these vectors analogously to
how you uh how matrix multiplication
computing a bunch of inner products
okay so um so
it turns out that you can solve this
problem faster
using these ideas which broke for uh
solving
orthogonal vectors faster um
so let me try to give a sense of the key
idea so so one is that if you're trying
to compute a min plus inner product
this is actually an easy problem with
respect to circuit complexity
um it's it's a bit counterintuitive but
like
if you think about it like uh if if i'm
like
let's say just for simplicity i'm i'm
writing down bit descriptions of all my
weights
i need to add weights together like
pairs of weights and then i
need to take a minimum of weights so
this is computable with so-called ac
0 circuits constant depth circuits with
and or not
okay of polynomial size so these are
somehow easy with respect to circuit
complexity
and then the second key idea was to use
techniques from lower bounds
um like things that were used to prove
lower bounds against ac0
and other classes to get some
algorithmic results so it turns out that
these easy inner products like this can
be reduced to polynomials over
f2 in a nice way so this nice polynomial
reduction i was trying to get
i can't get it the way i would like for
for cnsat but i can get it for these min
plus
uh inner products and it uses this
result of raspberry off and spelensky
there's some randomized reduction from
ac zero circuits of pi log degree
polynomials
um uh let me not go into
that we maybe if you want to know more
we can you can ask questions offline
but the point is this is something that
was used in uh to prove circuit
complexity lower bounds and we're using
an
algorithmic way here and then finally
like once i've reduced this
this min plus inner product to
evaluating a certain polynomial over a
bunch of assignments
then we can use things like fft we can
use things like
uh rectangular matrix multiplication to
evaluate these polynomials fast
okay and the the upshot is that we get
um in fact now it's been made
deterministic algorithm for all pairs
shortest paths
that runs in n cubed over two to the
square root of log n time
okay um so right n cubed is like what
floyd warshall gets you and then this is
like a
just a decisive improvement over uh in
cube running time
and it turns out this was a low one for
decades whether you could get say
n cubed over say a polylog factor for
like
and let's say the log cubed or log of
the four
um and it was obtained only by trying to
uh solve sat faster and failing okay
um so it's still open uh
whether apsp can be solved in the 2.999
time
um um i think this is
plausible it probably has to take a
different approach from the approaches
i've been taking but
it wouldn't surprise me if something
slightly related works maybe use more
structure
of the of the problem but in general
this approach had led to several papers
with josh allman and timothy chan on
finding exact
approximate nearest neighbors and
various metrics so this kind of
polynomial
trick so that led to another another uh
line of work and algorithms all right
um so i think this is my last uh
anecdote so a few years ago uh in
stanford i had an attack on the
so-called non-deterministic set so
you know i was like okay maybe you know
seth is a bit difficult uh maybe i can
attack something that seems weaker and
so the idea
was so what's not in terms of success
you to refute it
let me just say what it takes to refute
it you need to give a verifier algorithm
so that for every unsatisfiable cnf
there is a proof of size say 1.9 to the
n
so that this uh verifier on
uh f and p accepts and it runs in
1.9 and then time so the verifier runs
in 1.9 at a time
okay where n is number of variables
right so i wanna know whether these like
small proofs of unsatisfiability like
faster than two to the n
so something faster than just writing
down all the assignments and saying you
failed
uh on those right and it also should be
that for every satisfiable thing no such
proof exists so there's a
you know a complete and sound proof
system from satisfiability
um of course i i failed this too
um so i was trying to use polynomials
again uh
the way the approach i was looking at um
to abbreviate things i kept running into
polymer identity tests and i was trying
to like de-randomize
very particular polynomial identity
tests this is some notorious problem
in deranimization it seems to require
randomness
well as far as we know like probably it
doesn't probably there are deterministic
uh albums
uh for paranormal dna testing but um i
didn't want to have to do that in order
to
to refute the non-term success
so it turns out so russell and piazzo
mohammed baturi and students at ucsd
they sent
me a draft of their paper uh about
merlin arthur seth so they had some
version um like some extension on terms
except
and i realized i could at least refute
that so okay i
found a version of seth that i could
refute
that appeared in in ccc in in 2016
and so the theorem is uh given any
boolean formula of sub exponential size
there's a merlin arthur proof system for
determining the number of sad
assignments to f
using only uh two those n over two
time and it has two the n over two
length proofs
okay so so this is merlin arthur so what
it means is that
um so like i wanna know the number of
satisfying assignments
okay merlin will send me a proof of this
length
okay i am a randomized uh verifier
i have to follow like so i'm a
randomized algorithm that's what this
arthur thing is about
so it's like you know a randomized
version of non-deterministic seth
whether
the verifier algorithm is randomized so
if marilyn sends me a correct proof
claiming that the number of satisfying
assignments is is is
uh correct and it fits the proof format
i will accept with probability one but
if merlin sends me a claim
that it's a different number then i will
accept with only low probability okay um
and it works actually for any boolean
form this is the only place where you
know i can say something
uh it's like it's like just arbitrary
formulas here all right um
and trying to de-randomize this thing
you know and get uh say even prove that
non-internal success is false
uh seems seems pretty hard but
um hey you know um
who knows what can happen whenever you
fail uh you know
uh all right so let me conclude with
some open problems
uh so one uh i wanna
give more evidence that seth may be true
i mean maybe it is true
um i've been very productive assuming
that uh
it's false but you know maybe it's true
so you know maybe
like try to show that eth is equivalent
to seth in some way
um there are many known equivalences
within seth and one paper of this kind
is
uh segan adele from ccc2012 so they show
that like
cnf satisfiability is base equivalent to
like
sat for ac 0 linear size circuits for
like
more slightly more expressive circuits
getting faster albums of those is
equivalent to
getting faster along for cnf sets um
maybe prove that like the negation of
seth implies something actually unlikely
beyond faster algorithms so it's known
that if
seth is false then we get some circuit
lower bound but everyone expects the
circuit lower bound
to be true
so is there an interesting collapse of
complexity classes so all the
lower bound consequences we know of yeah
are expected so
so you know is there something unlikely
that happens if that is also i mean i
don't
i don't really know uh so is there more
evidence that seth is false okay
this is my my side um so there are
various
uh strengthenings of seth i have put
here super strong eth
which i think has been mentioned before
in some seminars
so prove just show that this dependence
on k and the exponent
can be improved so show that there's
some unbounded function f
so that k sat is in to the n minus
n times f of k over k so like let's say
let f k be like log k so like i can
subtract more from the exponent
than just a a factor of like 1 over k
um yeah i mean this
i mean this seems also false but it is
never less consistent with all the
albums we know of all like randomized uh
algorithms local search backtracking
they all
hit this wall of n minus n over k
so so it's still consistent with what we
know
and then this incest is something i i
talked about before non-deterministic
strong th
and then there's another version that i
actually don't know um
is false so give a arthur merlin person
so i talk about a merlin arthur
give an arthur merlin proof system for
unset where arthur speaks first so in
other words
the randomized algorithm tosses their
coins then based on those coins merlin
sends a proof
and then they um try to determine
unsatisfiability
so uh just a a warning like
if you show that am seth is false then
you probably
also show that there's a you know
non-deterministic
circuits uh that can prove unsatisfiably
faster so i mean
i mean it still seems
possible to me um why not i believe says
it's
false so why not um and then finally an
open-ended problem so given a sat solver
where sat solver can be whatever
you like if it runs in t time is there a
merlin arthur proof system so
so a proof system where you you can get
a proof of say unsatisfiability
and your randomized verifier you know
errors in its judgment of this proof
with like very low probability
is there a murder arthropodism for
verifying a trace and square root of t
time um so i have confirmed
this thing is true when the sat solver
is basically ppz
so with the mit undergrad we were able
to show that you can get a merlin art of
proof system that has like
square root of the running time of of pp
uh
z so this is slightly better than two to
the n over two
uh this is to the n over two minus like
n over k
roughly um this is a general open-ended
problem about like
uh a proof so i think like merlin arthur
proof system should be
considered more strongly um that's all i
have
uh sorry for going over thanks thanks
see there's a lot of questions so i have
a lot of work ahead of me now
thank you very much for the great talk
i'll applaud on behalf of everybody
and uh we have actually quite a few
comments or questions in the
chat window we don't currently have
anything in the q
a it doesn't look like yeah yeah so the
solving apsp
faster than n-cubed refute seth great
question
i don't know um
yeah we don't know of such a reduction
so i mean it it kind of
amounts to knowing um
whether solving apsp faster than n cubed
solves orthogonal vectors faster right
that would that would do it
um as far as we know um yeah
we we don't know we don't know of any uh
such reduction like between
all pairs shortest paths and orthogonal
vectors like so if you think of these
two
time solvable problems it kind of makes
more sense to try to do this reduction
yeah
so apsp seems a bit um
of an island in terms of fine-grained
stuff from that
from that point of view uh so you know
getting
faster albums for it is not going to
crash a whole bunch of other
conjectures that have been made unless
there's been a bunch more made in the
last couple years that i haven't noticed
but okay um
great question though all right
does deranimizing pit refute in seth
this is an interesting uh issue so
um it turns out that
um basically because of
the way in which we need to use pit um
it it doesn't so so notice we only got
let me go back yeah um
yeah so notice we only got a square root
improvement
uh over two to the n here right so we
would
um yeah like
we we would need uh some kind of
de-randomization
that is actually
um faster than
than like it's something beyond pit like
like we can in fact reduce this to a
univariate problem where i have a
circuit
of size let's say n and it's over one
variable
and it's of degree n okay and i want to
know if this is identically zero
okay with randomness you can you can
test
in basically linear time whether it's
identically zero by just
picking a random point over a
sufficiently large
field maybe extension if you need um
plugging it in for that one variable and
evaluating the linear size circuit
right but uh deterministically
um even if p i t is in polynomial time
deterministically
the best deterministic algorithm i know
of is you've got to evaluate the
polynomial and n plus one points
because it's degree n right so you got
to evaluate this pawn
on n plus one points and it's a r it's
not just a polynomial given as a sum of
uh terms in a nice way if you had you
know if it were like that then you could
use fft
to evaluate upon end points and like in
polylog n
no it's given as like an arithmetic
circuit uh so i
so i give you like the size and
arithmetic circuit over one variable
a degree n even deterministically even
if p i t is in p
um this seems to take in squared time
because i've got to evaluate n plus one
distinct points to know whether it's
identically zero
um so it's yeah
it's a but but still you could say like
if
if the you know for like a depth maybe
it's a depth 3
depth 4 i forget like a certain fixed
kind of circuit
over one variable if you could solve pit
for it faster
then yeah you would you would refute nsa
okay
yeah okay uh does this ma algorithm work
for circuits
um well it works for
linear size circuits because of this
really old result that says
linear size circuits are in order
n over log n depth once you've got
something of order n over log n depth
then you get a boolean formula of two to
the order n over log n
size but yeah i mean so
it works for circuits up to size like
slightly less than n log n
um because of this uh transformation i
guess due to patterson and valiant
um that a size a linear size circuit can
be
can be made to have slightly lower depth
but yeah for larger things no i don't
know let's say i had a circuit of two
little oven size
um yeah it
well it basically depends on the degree
of the of the circuit you get so you're
taking this formula you're arithmetizing
it
and you want the degree of that
polynomial you get from the
arithmetization to be small
so if it turns out that somehow you did
it for circuits in a way that where the
degree was not like
enormous then that would be fine
but yeah i don't i don't do that for
general
circuits
let's see does super strong
in seth uh fail
um super strong and seth yeah i don't
know
uh another great open question let's see
so proving seth hardness of apsp
requires refuting incest um
yeah so this this is this is from this
paper
of russell mohan and so on so
um yeah of course i refer i guess i
could have mentioned that but i believe
that incest is false
by the same slide um yeah so there
there they can show this because it
turns out
that non-deterministic ap there's a
non-terroristic
uh version of apsp conjecture um so
there is a non-terroristic algorithm
which will just solve a psp faster
than in cubes so non-interesting
algorithm
uh and codon interesting algorithm so
like it will just
generate uh the matrix product you want
and it will do so
in less than uh in cube time like
i don't know into the two point
something um so
if you had like a nice reduction um
showing right that aps p and ov are
related then
you would have a non-deterministic
algorithm for ov uh for proving
something doesn't have an orthogonal
pair
um and that would refute knowledge for
success but
yeah so this i mean what marvin is
pointing out is that aps this is reason
to believe that apsp may be
easier um but you know uh maybe there's
also non-terms of governance for
for showing non-orthogonal vectors as
well um
yeah similarly like we're getting
relation between like um
threesome nov seems hard because there
are non-terroristic ways to show that
the set does not have a
threesome solution good
good but yeah i guess i i could have
mentioned that but
yeah thanks
do you believe there are non-trivial
set algorithms for general boolean
circuits of poly size
if not is there a weaker class where you
draw the line um
yeah i i don't know um
[Music]
it doesn't i guess the main thing about
algorithm
running times of the form to the n over
n to the 100
is that it just looks so weak and
i don't know how many people actually
studied it um
yeah i i i don't know if i would like
say believe it strongly
but i just i don't see why i don't see
any like any reason to rule it out i
don't see any reason to think that like
general boolean circuits wouldn't have
um
to the n over n of the 100 time
algorithm
i mean yeah um
i just don't know i mean this is
probably you know
this is but of course i'm a guy who
proved
a theorem that said if circuit sat is
into the n over n of the hundred
then n x naught and p poly therefore we
should try to solve sat so i'm probably
the last guy you should ask
i'm a little biased maybe um i want the
hypothesis to be true i guess you know
implicitly so
yeah comment from paul in the same way
that mp completeness showed that
researchers and heart problems were
really working on satin didn't know it
i like to think of your results as
saying there are researchers on these
problems and p
working on satin just didn't know it
yeah i mean you're
refuting seth and not knowing it yeah um
although to me it seems it's like
refuting seth is not
going to me refuting says um
to me it signaled that refuting seth was
just like really easy because you're
like you could even go to pawn on time
problems and
solve them faster i i think but but yeah
but
i i like i like your way of putting it
paul it sounds like a nicer way of
framing my own work so
so do you think that
these better solutions uh for
problems in p type attacks are going to
be the way to refute seth
uh that leads me yeah that's i guess i
was just addressing that
um maybe not yeah maybe not um
[Music]
uh probably
the easiest way to refute uh seth
um would be to look more directly
at the formula uh and somehow
under actually understand albums that
run faster than exponential time rather
than
taking a mp hard problem reducing it to
paul time and then just running upon one
time algorithm
um that seems to be uh a better
a better way to try to refute seth uh i
just thought that it was i guess i was
so convinced that seth was false that i
thought it could be refuted this way
but it's probably an easier way to tell
you along the way i guess a lot of
theorems got proof so
so there's some some positive outcome
okay there's also a question in the q a
from all from alder corton
oh okay
for these mp2p type reductions like
saturn vectors
do they do they work for circuit lower
bounds too
showing a strong exponential circuit
lower bound for
sat implies a tight polynomial circuit
lower bounds for these problems
uh in p um
[Music]
sure um
yeah like so the reduction yeah
they would work for circuits as well um
if you had a
a better circuit for ov so you had a
circuit that was
subquadratic size uh for ov
um you would get a subquadratic oh sorry
a sub to the end
uh circuit for for c and f set
yeah so a strong exponential circuit
lower bound for set
contra positive we wouldn't get a tight
phone that's everywhere down
yeah okay vj
asks have parametrized other than clause
length
k versions of seth or eth been proposed
or studied um
yes i think so so
in the original paper z
so they show that if you parameterize by
the number of clauses
instead of the number of variables like
you're looking for a too little within
the low of m timeout where m's number
clauses
this is basically equivalent to getting
a two little of n uh time algorithm for
like at least for three sets
um
are there other parameterizations you
have in mind i guess the only parameters
we looked at were eminent
in this talk but
sometimes people look at things like
tree tree with there was a talk
yesterday by stephen cider about this
oh right yeah so there are definitely
there are definitely seth based
um lower bounds uh for like
solving various problems in tree width
so like
um it's difficult for me to reconstruct
them off the top of my head but like
say if the tree width is t and you want
us of some graph and you want to solve
this graph problem faster
in many cases there's a c to the t times
polynomial time algorithm
and it's known that if you got c minus
epsilon to the t
time for various uh for these various
problems
that then um things like seth would be
false
um so so they're they're
in fact relationships i guess between um
these kinds of things but yeah the
um i i that that is a
vast literature with lots of different
sub results so
um which i do not have random access to
in my head so
yeah so
okay thomas kochman has a question i
believe
f implies seth don't you
um
uh i don't know right i believe seth is
false
and eth might be true so i might not
believe that
uh
uh what um am i getting
so we know that seth implies f right
strong eth implied dth
um i don't know um
that would be interesting um i guess i
just throw it out there because it's
been when these questions have been
floating around for a long time trying
to understand
um it wouldn't surprise me if someone
came up with like some
uh unlikeliness result like it is
unlikely that we will prove
this kind of thing um yeah so
yeah i don't know i mean i i'm not like
yeah about about eth uh yeah i'm
i i don't know it's it's somehow it's
hard for me to think about like getting
a sub-exponential time algorithm for
there's only like a few things that i
can that come to mind but for seth
a lot of things came to mind for me so
that's why i kept you know thinking it's
false so i keep having ideas you know
that's my so here you go everybody
that's that's been my secret weapon
you're welcome um
would the failure of seth imply anything
about
collapses of complexity classes higher
up say in
an existential time or higher oh um
the failure um i don't know i
um yeah i i don't know of anything
unlikely like that um
yeah it's
yeah yeah i'm not i i don't know of
something like this
um i tend to think that the i mean
just as the implications go
that for higher complexity classes is
only more likely that say
non-determinism equals determinism but
um
so yeah um does this look good yeah i
don't know i
um yeah for all i know nx equals co and
x for something like that and
um you know
uh okay
all right if if there's no more
questions um
we'll thank ryan again i'll leave the
applause
thank you and everyone else should be
joining in um so
thank you ryan and christos as well he's
still here
for a delightful pair of talks
and uh so we have another
i guess there's a chance to meet in
gather town after this is that correct
i'm not sure
um otherwise uh there's a fellows talk
at eleven
and thank you again yeah how much time
is left uh yeah
i think i'll go to gather town uh which
which gather town i guess is that that's
the
oh oh um okay antonina antonina's
gathered town all right
i'm i'm going to anthony's gather town
and uh see you there
okay all right thank you very much see
you
bye